[Music]  red carpets galore Tuesday night and eat  easy to commute to all of them it's a  dream  so la-la-land cast stepped out for their  Paris premiere Ryan Gosling and Emma  Stone's first big appearance since  winning Golden Globes for the film over  the weekend meanwhile Margot Robbie  stunned at the Marie Claire image-maker  Awards with her new wedding ring on full  display she was there to honor her  makeup artist  it's totally surreal I mean she flew in  for this yes I mean she's on the ground  for less than ten hours or something  kylie jenner also stepped out for the  Marie Claire event looking perfect in  purple she changed into this white  number for a date with boyfriend Tyga  after the or  [Music]  you